everyone and welcome to the hunter of
hunters challenge so a couple of weeks
ago I put out the call to you guys to
submit clips of you killing as many
hunters as you could in 15 minutes and
you guys did really well we got about a
hundred submissions and who you're
seeing on screen now
our first second and third place out of
those 100 submissions and let me tell
you these guys did amazingly and the top
left we have gray in the top right we
have winter and in the bottom left we
have arcane and they have little symbols
that represent their names but these
aren't in any particular order we're
just gonna watch them race now and we're
going to see who got to the end first
who killed five hunters in the shortest
amount of time and what different
strategies each character used I mean
even this early in the clips you can
already see a few unique elements of
each run taking shape
for example gray in the top left he was
the only one who got those two blood
valves from his safe cos clinic the
other two have zero blood vials and that
just goes to show how fine tune did
these runs are I mean it would have
taken them about five seconds to get
those extra blood vials but these guys
are in the top three because they don't
plan on using those blood files because
they don't plan on getting hit the one
thing they all did get with a Molotov
cocktails which are a very important
tool and right here we noticed the first
major difference in these runs that was
the most efficient time to go to the
hunters drain and gray has decided to
forgo it completely
now that was actually a fairly uncommon
thing compared to the other runs that I
received most people decided to brave
that terrible loading screen and go and
get their weapons of choice most of the
time their weapons of choice were the
hunters acts and the blunderbuss
in the bottom left are cane picks up the
axe and heads back to central yharnam
but in the top right winter gets the axe
and the blunderbuss which turns out to
influence the way he plays and that's
the thing we notice each of these
characters now has different tools and
they have different strengths and
different weaknesses based on those
tools for example gray in the top left
he just picked up some oil urns which
will allow him to do more damage with
Molotov cocktail
and he can afford to do this because
he's in the lead but it's also necessary
for him to do this because compared to
the other two he's going to have a much
weaker weapon as I'm sure a lot of you
have guessed
he's currently running towards the
source pier now the sauce pier is a good
weapon but it's not the best weapon for
taking out hunters it doesn't have the
ability to stagger hunters as
effectively as the hunters axe does and
because he doesn't have a gun it also
means that he'll have to find new
strategies to take them out luckily
weapons don't matter too much in this
fight with Eileen he starts us off with
an oil urn and a Molotov followed by a
visceral attack and another Molotov
cocktail now he's gonna leg it back to
the rafters and he's going to try and
get Eileen to fall off at the point
where she can take the most damage from
falling all three of them use this
technique and Grey has no real trouble
taking out Arlene here she can throw
knives which can make that encounter a
little bit longer but he pretty much did
that as fast as possible the only thing
that is adding to his timer here is the
time it takes him to pick up the sauce
spear from start to finish
crazed encounter with Eileen takes
exactly 30 seconds if you cast your eyes
down to the bottom left we see arcane
preparing for his fight with Eileen and
just a fraction behind him is winter
both of these players have Molotov
cocktails equipped in their hot bars and
arcane puts them to good use here he
starts off his encounter in the fastest
way possible by lobbing four Molotov
cocktails that Eileen before noticing
that she's become hostile on the other
hand winter in the top right employs a
tactic similar to grey by visceral
attack and art towing her until she's
low enough arcane his run back to the
rafters and he's waiting for Eileen but
he gets really unlucky here and she
starts pegging knives at him so he lost
a little bit of time there on the top
right winter is waiting for Eileen he
gets the perfect drop and also the
perfect drop down to the sewers you can
notice that he actually caught up to our
cane by doing a perfect jump down there
right now they all have one hunter
killed winter and arcane are still
arch-nemesis and gray is about to start
his encounter with Gascoigne and this is
the point where you'd be surprised how
quickly that arcane and win
to catch up to gray he has a huge head
start here they still have to go to the
end of the sewers and go up the ladders
but gray has to deal with using this
week a weapon on Gascoigne that said he
does have a fairly good fight with him
especially towards the second half
you'll see what I mean
so he's forced to go with a safe option
of getting Gascoigne stuck behind the
graves it's definitely a safer option
but you can see here that his weapon is
really just chipping away at his health
the real damage that gray does in this
fight is through perfect use of oil and
molotovs so as soon as Gascoigne
transforms into his two-handed axe mode
it's no longer a good idea for him to
try and hit him behind the graves he's
already getting hit a few times and as
soon as Gascoigne lengthens that axe
there's pretty much no hope that he's
gonna effectively be able to hit him
perfectly timed oil urn there as well as
a perfectly timed Molotov that follows
it up and at this point in the clips
there's too much going on I can't
comment on everything in the top left
gray times a Molotov at the exact moment
Gascoigne transforms and it does a huge
amount of damage in the bottom left
arcane manages to get Gascoigne stuck on
the stairs which allows him to chip away
at his health very slowly but also very
safely but in the top right look how
fast winter is killing Gascoigne with a
combination of Molotov cocktails
perfectly timed visceral attacks and
charged Artoo's he is absolutely
decimating Gascoigne and I think he
actually kills him in 56 seconds which
is the record for these three even when
he goes into beast form he still takes
him out perfectly those charged
one-handed acts are twos are absolutely
insane even in beast form he gets
staggered but that's the Gascoigne for
winter so congratulations on the fastest
Gascoyne kill I've ever seen and arcane
in the bottom left he's still chipping
away but he does make up a fair amount
of time by using Molotov cocktails here
they do a massive amount of damage when
he's in beast form so six minutes in and
all three hunters have to hunter kills
under their belt in the lead still is
gray in the top left and he's preparing
for his fight with Alfred Alfred is the
key to killing five hunters when I
announced this challenge
I managed to kill three hunters and I
knew it would be possible
kill four but I didn't really expect
anyone to kill five I was proven
completely wrong there were quite a lot
of five hunter kill submissions and all
of them contained Alfred
now he's difficult to kill for a couple
of reasons but the main one I reckon is
the fact that his shotgun can one-shot
you it's very hard to dodge those
shotgun blasts so in all of these clips
the players have to manage to keep him
in his hammer form or keep him stun
locked the entire time and all three of
them have very different techniques for
taking him out so gray starts off the
encounter by getting the fire paper from
Alfred and as soon as he cooperates with
him he stabs him in the back with his
fiery saw spear this is followed up by a
technique that I only learned from
watching him if you backstab Alfred and
then you follow it up with a Molotov
cocktail while he's switching out his
weapons you can actually get another
visceral attack so watch him here he
does it now Molotov and another back
step you can't do this over and over
again now that he has his weapons out
alfred is going to react so he begs
another Molotov and now it's time to use
up all that stamina get as much damage
as you can and lure him back to the
doorway and then arcane just went
through so now all three hunters are
engaging Alfred and they all take him
out in a completely different way which
is great to watch so in the top left
gray is luring Alfred to the doorway
because he wants to get Alfred stuck
outside of his aggro range and whenever
an NPC is outside of their aggro range
they desperately try to run back inside
that aggro range but they can't attack
while they're running so if you manage
to balance Alfred on your character then
he won't be able to enter back into the
aggro range this is really dangerous
which is why the other two don't do it
and you notice a few times in Gray's
footage that he actually gets hit by
Alfred but he has no other choice he has
to do this to Alfred because he doesn't
have a hunter's axe and as you can see
the other two are making very good use
of that hunters axe in the top right
winter is getting Alfred stuck in a
visceral attack cycle which is done by
flattening him with our - following up
with two shotgun blasts and then
a visceral attack he comes very close to
dying here because some torch guy in the
background actually hit him through the
fence winter does manage to kill Alfred
here but unfortunately he has to wait to
get the fire paper from Alfred and I
think he lost a little bit of time by
not getting that fire paper beforehand
so three hunters for the top two and
arcane is close behind just whittling
away at Alfred with that are two spin
attack it's certainly one of the more
difficult ways of killing Alfred arcane
actually comes quite close to death in a
moment here the thing I like most about
the Alfred part of the challenge is that
everyone had such a different way of
dealing with him and each one of those
ways was indicative of the tools that
they had and it all goes back to those
decisions they made at the hunters dream
so right now
gray is in the lead he's just entering
old yharnam and as I'm sure a lot of you
can guess again they're going to be
going for the two hunters in old yharnam
so there's a source spear hunter coming
up and then there's juror at the top of
the tower this is it who do you thinks
gonna win so gray faces some
complications he is in the lead but
think about how difficult it's going to
be to knock off Jorah from the top of
his tower and deal damage to this sauce
spear hunter winter has those advantages
he can shoot Durer off the tower he can
poke him with his long-range axe and
even our Kaine has the axe with the fire
paper so he can deal a lot of damage
this does get close so right now
Grey has engaged the sauce bear hunter
he's using his favor tactic of dodging
out of the way at the last second then
knocking him outside of his aggro range
and winter decides to actually run past
the saw spear hunter he's going straight
for Jura
at first I thought he was gonna lose
time by doing this but it actually takes
a long time for juror to fall off the
tower and count as a death so it does
make sense doing juror first and you're
seeing how little damage that sauce
spear is doing to the sauce bear hunter
winter is absolutely catching up and in
a moment if he successfully kills juror
he's gonna have four hunters killed to
cast your eyes down to arcane for a
moment here because he has perfected the
art of killing the saw spear hunter
winter
poked juror off the top of his tower and
winter is in the lead with four hunters
kills however gray is close behind he
kills the saw spear hunter now winter
and gray have four hunters killed gray
is climbing the tower to get his last
kill winter is about to try and kill the
saw spear hunter he's got to be quick
but look how quick arcane is killing
that hunter with the axe that is the
advantage that winter has alright so he
stooped him and is getting ready to
attack here he's doing a fair bit of
damage gray is climbing that tower he's
gonna have a lot of trouble killing
juror here he goes
three dashes one through the shotgun
blasts one shotgun blast goes under his
arm juror falls down the tower it takes
a long time for his echoes to count but
there it is gray gets five hunters
killed in 11 minutes and 50 seconds and
now it's a fight for second place arcane
is at the top of the tower he's gonna
use the same method of poking jura jura
has fallen the saw spear hunter has died
which ones echoes will come first winter
gets it arcane one and a half seconds
afterwards first place
coming in at 11 minutes and 50 seconds
is grey second place coming in at 12
minutes and four seconds is winter and
with only about one and a half seconds
between them arcane comes in third place
at 12 minutes and six seconds he did a
brilliant job at catching up at the end
there so congratulations to our winners
you can find their YouTube channels in
the description so give them a
subscription and see if our talented
runners can come out with some videos in
the next few weeks on top of that though
congratulations to all of the
contestants and all over the entrance I
had such a brilliant time going through
all the submissions every single one I
watched was really exciting and every
time that I thought that I had seen the
fastest run I was like yep no one can do
that faster but every single time I said
that I got a new submission the next day
that was even faster than that and
watching them all was really exciting
our special mention to the hunters that
decided to lure this sauce spear hunter
off this ladder I thought that was funny
and lastly a huge thank you to
Playstation
sponsoring this competition that was so
appreciated I'll be contacting the
winners of this challenge and the
nightmare challenge as well and as a
result of this challenge I hope someone
new can get to experience the wonder
that is blood-borne because we did have
a couple of ps4s up for grabs so I'll
see you all in the next one and if I
have an idea for another challenge I
think I'll let you know in another video
or on Twitter as I'm not quite sure
where to take this series at the moment
but cheers guys thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]